why don't we go next to oh I don't know
how about Seth from Nebraska Seth
welcome to the program what's on your
mind today
Seth from Nebraska please accept my
invitation sir if you would like to talk
to me
Seth welcome
Seth you're on but I'm not hearing you
one opportunity you got to change your
audio device to one that works
all right and there goes Seth from
Nebraska how about uh Jamie from South
Dakota Jamie from South Dakota welcome
to the program what is on your mind
today Jamie
hello David can you hear me yes I can
okay I had a question about the uh
United States and NATO okay so high blue
so I believe that uh Joe Biden has done
a good job uh with like not sending uh
U.S troops but providing Aid and keeping
the US and the EU cohesively together
okay but I was just wondering what you
thought of like the pro uh the
anti-ukraine or pro-putin sentiment
um like from like Tucker Carlson or uh
some Republicans and how that could
damage our uh relationship with the EU
well moving forward on on a personal
level I find the soft Putin defenses
pretty vile and I don't care who's doing
them because as a progressive
anti-authoritarian I'm not big on
authoritarian autocrats so I'm not big
on Putin and I'm not big on duterte and
I'm not big on erdogan or bolsonaro or
so as a matter of principle I disagree
now you're going to the next layer which
is important to do which is
if they got their way in terms of if
American policy more closely mirrored
Tucker's view rather than what we have
what would that do for our alliances and
relationships and I think it would be
hugely damaging I think it would it
would affiliate us with the worst of the
global authoritarian autocrats it would
alienate us from many of our historical
allies where we share more values we
don't necessarily share all values but
we share more so I think it would be
disastrous politically in that way as
well
yes exactly that's what I think as well
yeah uh thank you for taking my question
David what's it what's it like in South
Dakota tell me do you live rurally or in
a city
I live rurally in South Dakota how how
rural give me a sense
uh we have uh 2500 people wow okay 25
000 people 25 000 people oh 25 000. oh
that's not that small
yep so we're about the third uh most
populated city in the state and it's uh
it's pretty conservative
um a little a little too much now if you
wanted for example to fly somewhere far
away let's say you wanted to fly to
Europe how close is the airport you
would drive to to start that trip
um
well we have a airport in in town but
like the biggest city that you'd go for
like a flight like that would be Sioux
Falls and it's three hours away okay so
you would but I'm guessing like can you
get to Chicago from where you live from
that small airport no no oh yeah the
only airport you uh our airport only
goes to uh Minneapolis Minnesota oh okay
well but so then you could fly to
Minneapolis and then get like a Delta
flight to Europe so that's not that bad
actually that's pretty well connected
yep okay all right very good well just
curious Jamie from South Dakota great to
hear from you hope you have a good day
David all right you two have a good one
appreciate it just a reminder to
everybody who wants to talk to me if you
have like an obvious nickname or just a
name and no location in your nickname
that I see you're not gonna get called
on the format is name and where you're
calling from or where you're calling
from and your name or whatever obviously
I don't know if it's your real name but
if it's like a vulgar joke rather than a
plausible name you're also not going to
get called on just so people know